[Music]  et has the latest on Brad Pitt's  relationship with his kids you know we  want to make it a family affair and have  the kids running in and out a source  close to the actor tells ET all six of  Brad's children visited him at his Los  angeles-area home earlier this month  according to our source that was the  first family visit to the house in a  while quite possibly since news broke  that Brad and Angelina Jolie were  splitting up our source said it's been  quiet around Brad's compound since the  announcement the former couple is still  working out the terms of their divorce  but a source told ET in March that they  are speaking directly in the past you  described Brad often as a wonderful  father of course is part of the family  do you still believe that  of course of course look we will always  be a family  always  [Music]  you